mountain snow we need that too all right
let's get to the roads we need a good
commute we have that for the most part
on the freeways we're still dealing with
this fatal crash that happened at 1 30
this morning so now almost five hours
into this investigation you cannot get
through sahara and rainbow because of
this fatal crash photojournalist henry
takayam went out there earlier this
morning as metro police began their
investigation we have not yet been told
whether the victim in this deadly crash
was the dui driver or the driver of the
other vehicle but the bottom line for
you you're trying to figure out how to
get around now we have a live look from
the regional transportation commission
northbound rainbow closed as is east and
westbound sahara so if you're southbound
on rainbow just get off on charleston or
okey go east over to jones or west over
to buffalo same thing if you're coming
from the south north on rainbow to d.i
or spring mountain over to jones or to
buffalo we are getting report of a crash
now in the far northeast valley this is
at lake mead and hollywood not exactly
the middle of nowhere because there's
definitely a lot of people living out
there this crash is on eastbound lake
mead just east of hollywood keep an eye
out for that one john heather